la réforme bioéthique nous la voterons
et le plus tôt sera le mieux nous
l'adopterons définitivement avant la fin
du quinquennat mais pas seulement avant
la fin des quinas beaucoup plus vite que
la fin du quinquennat
j'ai dit à l'hôtel 3 jeter vos confrères
d'une autre chaîne de télévision que ça
serait très difficile avant l'été si
c'est possible pourquoi pas mais j'ai du
mal à l'imaginer mais très vite après
l'été il faut que cette loi soit adoptée
les retraites c'est différent les
circonstances ont changé et notamment la
question du financement des retraites la
question du travail prendre évidemment
une autre couleur à l'aune de la crise
que nous vivons est donc il faudra
probablement l'adapter